the engine is set I'm bring cough in
Berlin it's time to talk a typhoons
terror the world rushing in to help the
Philippines are we doing enough are we
to blame pictures that paint a thousand
questions the mystery of a huge art find
immunity and a nest of spies and a haven
for hacktivists welcome to Berlin
welcome to the show everyone I have
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my first
guest is Berlin's top security guard for
all information classified for your eyes
only I am happy to welcome to the show
Alexander Dixie is the Data Protection
Commissioner for the government of
Berlin Alexander good to have you on the
show my second guest is known as a kind
of James Bond in the murky world of
tracking down sellers and dealers and
reuniting art with its rightful owners
I'm happy to welcome to the show Vili
corte he is going to be lending us his
double oh seven senses today to talk
about this Munich story really it's good
to have you on the show and my next
guest is a religious leader in the
Filipino community right here in Berlin
I'm happy to welcome father Simon boys
are to the show he's a Catholic priest
from the Philippines with a congregation
right here in Berlin father assignment
let's just start out by asking have you
and your congregation have you been able
to find out what's going on in the
Philippines have you been able to make
contact with people back home since the
past two days we've been trying to make
contacts with our relatives and families
in the Philippines it's quite difficult
to have this context we authority
through call through telephones that we
could not establish some contacts so
we're able to contact some people
through the internet through emails and
through Facebook and what are you
hearing they took there are very very
chaotic some Filipinos feel they are
quite shocked by the magnitude of this
catastrophe there are people say there
are still looking for their missing
family members there are people who are
trying to organize some relief goods
they have problems with the
transportation let me just ask all of
the year at the table with me today the
impact of this disaster do you think the
world is realized exactly what has
happened to the Philippines what would
you say well I think it always takes
a certain amount of time to realize that
that's a huge disaster one of the
strongest typhoons ever to be have been
registered but I think I hope the world
will wake up to this challenge and and
react appropriately very soon we're
going to talk about reactions just a
second really what would you say well I
was in New York not too long ago when
her kin sandy hit and that's supposed to
be a very well-organized place and
everything broke down in southern
Manhattan so I can only imagine what it
means for the people in a country like
Philippines that were even hit harder
than then hurrican sandy hit New York
definitely and fellow some of the people
in the Philippines mean they had a
warning that a monster storm was
approaching didn't they they have this
warning already two days before the
catastrophe came but the people not all
of them have the access to
communications not all of them have
televisions and radios the military's
came there and send people away but they
use they were find refuge in churches in
schools but that was not a safe place
yeah we've got some staggering numbers
that are coming out of the Philippines
in the wake of typhoon hye-young want to
read those for you the Red Cross says
that it has placed an initial order for
10,000 body bags in just one of the
devastated villages in the path of the
storm more than 400 bodies have been
counted a mass grave is where they are
being buried UNICEF estimates that 10
million people have been impacted by
this disaster about half of them are
children and just this week 12 thousand
women are expected to give birth in the
middle of this misery well their health
at this point cannot be guaranteed
typhoon Haiyan is the worst natural
disaster ever to hit the Philippines
hundreds of people have already been
confirmed dead but authorities fear the
death toll could surpass 10,000 and this
despite large-scale preventive safety
measures before the storm hit Philippine
authorities had moved some 800,000
people too sturdy evacuation centers
schools churches and other
like buildings but there are no match
for the extreme winds of super typhoon
haiyan or yolanda as it's being called
in the philippines now the big problem
is getting aid to the survivors a
logistical challenge for the poor
Southeast Asian archipelago nation of
over 7,000 islands roads transportation
and communications have been devastated
by the storm the philippine president
has declared a state of national
calamity father Simon you know we've got
people watching us around the world lots
of Filipinos watching who are not in the
Philippines they go to church is just
like yours what are you telling your
congregation here in Berlin how can they
help and how should they deal with this
catastrophe last Sunday we had our holy
mess and we began this holy mess without
one minute of silence praying for the
victims in the Philippines and he also
said that our masks elections will be
sent to the victims of the Philippines
and these coming weeks we are going to
send our collections we are also open
for donations from from all over the
country and since Sunday there are
donations coming into our parishes that
are willing to give anything we're not
rejecting any help we are very thankful
for this and we hope we could do more
than praying and more than collecting
things on donations we are still trying
to coordinate our actions here in Berlin
alright what are you able to do here in
Berlin besides praying I mean talk to me
about the help that you're getting right
now we're trying to contact some people
in the Philippines some of my confer
some of my colleagues working in this
region and Dre trying to tell us that
they stay in the help there are
logistical problems happening the
Philippines they're very thankful that
the international community is helping
the Philippines from all over the world
we are we're watching the development of
events and we're trying to try to relate
information to other people trying to
contact Filipinos living in Germany that
we should help is I want to talk about
the international response but let me
ask you coming from the Philippines is
the Filipino government doing all that
it can and all that it should this has
been the the major actions of the
government in the past months last month
there was a strong earthquake which also
be felled a near this region and the
person of the Philippines came there the
government is trying to help the people
trying to be present among the people
but I have the impression that the
government is also kind of a they are
not up to up to the task that's why we
are very happy that the international
community is helping us and when you say
the international community who do you
mean specifically we have received help
from the US from the UK and from Europe
okay let me ask other than Alexander and
Billy what about this international
relief effort right now I mean there is
no way that any country can deal with
what this Thai food has done what I'm
just wondering how how well organized
was the help since since the the storm
was announced way in advance I mean what
was the government in communication with
the international community I mean was
everybody ready for the storm because
you said the government is overwhelmed
some of the militaries and soldiers when
today is southern part of the
Philippines where this earthquake
happened and they're sending airplanes
to this region beforehand and they were
able to lift people out of the region
but there were not enough airplanes and
helicopters because we hear this
regularly after this is a so that one
could have been better prepared and I
wonder when is when is it going to
happen that we will be well I I think in
the Philippines what I've been reading
what our reporters are telling us is
that it's an issue of being prepared but
it's also an issue of what people are
willing to do without being forced to do
and everyone along the coastal regions
which is where most people live we're
told to evacuate and to go to safety
centers but obviously they didn't do
that and the question is ok we have a
disaster now so there are some voices
coming out and saying well
who should get help now the people who
evacuated or the people who didn't
that's a nice point because some people
are if you don't want to leave their
houses willingly they say if I will go
back do I still find my house i still
find my belongings so it's quite
difficult sometimes to convince people
to get out of the area and some people
say i believe in god i trust in His
mercy I could just stay here and if I
have luck I could survive well we have
to say the United States people build on
the beach where their houses are being
hit you know whenever a hurricane comes
comes on shore and yeah they don't seem
to want to move either but they but the
government isn't it the job the
government's job Alexander GT isn't it
the government's job to make it harder
for people to live for people to stay in
places where we know natural disasters
are going to hit well we had a flood not
too cannot to be compared with what's
happening the Philippines right now but
in Germany where floodings this summer
in and the river elbe went left his bed
and then destroyed a couple of cities
very badly and we had a discussion
beforehand what can be done to prevent
this happening again in the future by
providing for spaces where nothing
should be built in the future anymore so
even sort of tearing down buildings or
banning farmers to to farmland in these
spaces just to leave it to the to the to
the river to be as a kind of reservoir
in kind of highway in terms of high
water but that has to be has to be
legislated for it has to be done by the
government and provided for their strong
resistance in the in the population in
the communities get such measures it's a
difficult political task but I agree
this has to be some some measures have
to be taken by the government otherwise
it won't be followed I'm wondering if
the Filipino government's doing that I
mean you know we've got the UN climate
talks taking place right now in Warsaw
and the Philippines has wasted no time
drawing a connection between the typhoon
and and climate change and they've made
an appeal for a deal to be reached at
the climate talks and for
thing to be done are the Philippines
like many developing countries are they
trying to put the bill on the table of
the developed world I think there's
enough laws or bills in the Philippine
government regarding this issue but I
think the present government has many
tests to fulfill they have a list of
priorities there is this task of
fighting corruption in the government
there's just s of alleviating the
poverty in the in the country so i think
this prevention of natural disasters or
helping the the risk of suffering from
that disasters is not in the top
priority list but on this year since
they say that there's an average of
twenty big typhoon separating the
philippines then maybe it is high time
now to give more time and money for this
issue father Simon what about the
world's moral responsibility we here in
the West we know that we're the biggest
polluters we have been for the past
century don't we have a moral obligation
than to help parts of the world that are
going to suffer because of climate
change and suffer because of these
storms I don't know if I am in the
position to play it blame on anybody
else but I noticed among the Philippines
if you are asked them who is to blame
for this calamity and some people will
think they will think directly about God
because you know the Filipinos are
spiritual people they tend to explain
what is happening to them through the
eyes of their faith through the eyes of
their religion so maybe they will say
maybe it's part of my sin or I have to
atone for my sins it's to do with my
relationship with God maybe in Europe if
something similar is happening they will
explain it through the global warming or
the climate change yeah I mean there's
the explanation we're getting this is
climate change now we're getting the
bill for for everything I mean what
about the responsibility of the rest of
the world feeling well it seems to be
exceedingly difficult to come to some
sort of compromise that is accepted by
everybody I don't know how long these
international efforts have been going on
I don't even remember but it must have
been many years and if I remember
correctly if I remember correctly
there's always somebody usually some
tree or some group of countries that
can't agree with a certain provision
within whatever agreement they seem to
be working on so I'm not sure that that
we are making great progress in terms of
being proactive is it our responsibility
I well it is but I think we are
basically just responding reactively to
the next disaster is that the future
will continue to react Alexander or do
we need to own up to what we've done I
think we have to we have to be more
proactive and reach some kind of
compromises really quarter has said and
I would like to add to come back what
father Simon said in the beginning the
lack of information on the ground for
for many people so access to information
and communications means should be
should be evenly distributed around the
globe and if we sort of help the
Philippines and other countries and in
this situation we should also sort of
look to to improve the communication and
communication infrastructure that's very
important I know you know we've got
these big military shipments coming in
from the US and the UK which is
obviously a strong sign of help but I
want to read you something that was on
the cover of the Financial Times today
there was an article obviously about the
UK sitting in six billion dollars worth
of aid to the Philippines today and
under that was an article about a banker
from the city in London complaining
about his bonus this year only being
around four billion dollars where is the
where is reason here are we not
obviously we're not doing enough to help
people in trouble if a banker can earn
four billion dollars this is a very
universal question about social justice
in the world and how do we divide our
our wealth in the world and I think we
could discuss and philosophize about
this but in this situation now in the
Philippines we are really very thankful
for every
we could get from the government I mean
I was four minutes 4 million I want to
clear that he has four million its
familiar there I would like to get back
to what you have said it's you know
people have plenty of suggestions and
how to solve this problem they have
always a suggestion how to to recognize
to make this long recovery program and
they should build more infrastructures
but I think it's a question of resources
also when natural disasters are
happening throughout the country in a
span of three months almost every week
how could you respond there it seems
that you're losing resources and you
have limited time to respond before we
move on father time in your obviously
this is also your home where do you see
the Philippines going from here it's
really quite difficult now to make a
picture of this we've been thinking or
yeah this is not the end of these
catastrophes now I if you base it on the
statistics we are still expecting more
storms in the coming in coming weeks and
maybe next year this the storms will
come maybe not as strong as the storm
last Saturday so I think it's really
quite difficult really to have these
recoveries and the question of the human
essence the people who suffered who lost
their families that the time to grieve
it's really quite complicated yeah we
certainly do wish the people of the
Philippines all the best as we move
forward from this we want to move on and
we want to move to a case with seemingly
more questions than answers at this
point and it forces Germany's government
its people and the art world to once
again confront the crimes of the Nazis
last week an amazing find came to light
in early 2012 tax collectors in Munich
found an estimated 1 billion euros worth
of art stashed in an apartment why it
took almost two years for the
authorities to make the discovery public
is just one of the mysteries in the case
accompanied by ghosts of the past
what's being called a Nazi art trove
1400 artworks worth up to 1 billion
euros was found in the Munich apartment
of Cornelius Gurlitt the son of powerful
Nazi era art dealer Hildebrand Gurlitt
many of the works by such artists as
Picasso Matisse Lenoir Marc Chagall and
Otto Dix are believed to have been
seized by the Hitler regime even though
German tax authorities confiscated the
collection and early 2012 the story has
only just come to light sparking
criticism of Germany for dragging its
feet on the restitution of artworks
seized by the Nazis now under pressure
from abroad German prosecutors have
commissioned a task force to speed up
the process and revealed that hundreds
of the paintings may have been stolen
from Jewish owners were bought from them
under duress Vili what's your take on
this I mean you've been on cases like
this before why is it taking the
government so long to present this
information to the public well the
government didn't really decide on its
own to present anything as you know they
were basically he's caught with their
pants down by it being in the press a
week ago I am somewhat amazed how
considering the ingredients of this case
meaning a story from the Nazi past
Jewish assets associated with the Nazi
past in other words something that that
Germany has gone through several times
over this last 20 years that Berlin
government didn't intervene and take
over so to speak from the very beginning
including do you think berlin new there
from the very beginning i mean these
things been going on since early 2012
well and apparently besides the
authorities in bavaria berlin didn't do
anything with it and that's what amazes
me that they let this go on for a year
and a half in munich in Augsburg with
the authorities yeah without setting up
some sort of an infrastructure whereby
you know various institutions
individuals wouldn't get involved
including of course a a PR strategy how
are we going to present this to the
public and how are we going to
continue then working with this with the
public's eye on this whole story the
district attorney in Augsburg he's on
this case and he said this is a criminal
case we're talking about tax evasion
right now Alexander the district
attorney is appealing to privacy laws in
Germany and he says the privacy laws
surrounding a criminal case right now
have top priority so he's singing your
song isn't he well I'm not only a Data
Protection Commissioner but also Freedom
of Information Commission so I think the
balance that has to be struck here is
between privacy and the public interest
in certain information and I believe
they used privacy as a pretext not to
disclose information they could have
disclosed information earlier I I don't
know what happened during the last one
and a half years what they did
apparently they did not realize the
sheer dimension of what they actually
found yeah and really do you believe
that you believe they didn't realize
what they had on their hands well it
seems to be that way but about I
understand how is that they couldn't
have realized it again we have had these
stories about you know various aspect of
the Nazi Paris before and it's always
the same for development you know the
whole world takes an interest pressure
mounts from New York London Tel Aviv the
government has to respond the the
demands always the same openness
transparency you know the world needs to
be able to see understand what's going
on so so everything that I think
happened or didn't happen in last year
and a half sort of seems to be wrong
from from that that perspective because
the prosecutor obviously in Augsburg is
not there to sort out 1400 works of art
he has allegedly a text violation to
deal with right and the research shows
that they had one person one art
historian helping them on this case and
maybe maybe they were over burdened by
it who knows what does you
our detective knows tell you about this
case i mean the the man who was in the
apartment where this art was found we
don't really know where he is right now
but he's a free man there's no arrest
warrant out for him on tax evasion
charges on anything well his father
hildebrand good was obviously a very
prominent art dealer in a Nazi period
and his two main projects were one
dealing with the so-called degenerate
art and to providing works of art
particular from France and his case for
what was then called the Lin's Hitler
Museum so he was involved in two major
art transaction projects and the art
that that has reappeared seems to
reflect that in terms of what it is and
way came from what what I think was
overlooked also is that that of course
Hildebrand Gurlitt has a long track
record in in the archives what what
surprised me is when I heard the story
there was talk about works of art and a
great deal of speculation about the art
without anybody haven't looked at
apparently of the records from the Nazi
period as well as the post-war period
where Goulet you know was interviewed
interrogated some of his art was seized
right so so that apparently was was
overlooked now when you look at the art
itself its may be exceedingly difficult
to sort every piece L yeah and it is
there a guarantee now that we're going
to know who the original owners were of
all what do we have 1400 pieces here no
but it is there so is there agreement is
there an agreement or some type of
treaty that guarantees that the original
owners have a right to reclaim the art
there is nothing on the German law it
may be very difficult for the heirs of
former Jewish owners who lost their
works of art during a Nazi period why is
that I mean the world would think that
for you know the descendants of Jewish
victims of the Nazis that it would be
very easy today we have no provisions in
German law you know today on the books
that that accommodate that request there
are no international binding agreements
legally binding
women's for Germany as for the
government to step in for argument's
sake for now everything is private
property of mr. Gurley so it's well it's
basically Finders Keepers is what you're
saying unless mr. Gurlitt says I don't
want it anymore unless he gives it up
unless that's some sort of deal but I
have to tell it from my own experience I
have made many claims on behalf of
Jewish airs in this country with private
collectors or you know with the trade
where things reappear and my success
rate is very discouraging so I'm afraid
from a legal point of view strictly
legal point this may end up being a
rather disappointing story for many many
people well father Simon what about
public pressure here on mr. Gurley is
there some force there do you think that
could work for a greater good to get
this art returned to the people that it
was taken from I think this issue is a
mixture of political poetic politics and
a moral issue and I have the impression
that whatever the government does it
might be wrong it might be right and the
media are trying to you know press
forward on own decisions and I think
it's in German that there's a complex
legal system you could not just force an
investigation the investigations not yet
over but people want results I'm read
that there is a possibility it's being
thrown out maybe as a trial balloon that
mr. gurlitt's could be offered this
settlement okay we won't press tax
evasion charges but you have to give up
all the art well I don't know whether
that's a very attractive deal that
clearly is millions many millions of
dollars worth of art at stake a billion
is well and that may be a bit bitter as
domestic but certainly a considerable
amount of money at stake and mr. Gurlitt
would have to have a very serious text
problem don't you think so in order to
in order to you know lose this art
collection I'm still not quite sure
where the the connection really is
between
these texts charges which haven't been
specified and the seizure of the artwork
I'm not quite sure how how does you know
really you're right there's not a lot of
information out there for us to go on
but what I've been able to put together
is tax collectors basically went to his
apartment because they had failed and
with written correspondence to get in
touch with him and they had questions
for him and when they went into the
apartment this is what they found and
Germany as we know right now is getting
really hard on tax evaders and I can't
imagine that the tax man would have
looked at this case and said we're just
going to let it go yeah but I also read
in the newspapers that the man had a
bank account with with a you know a
serious amount of money in it and and
why was that not enough and on top of
the prosecutor seems to indicate that
he's not interested in in the current
location of mr. Gurlitt that doesn't
seem to be a flight risk associated with
him he doesn't seem to be interested in
talking to him so you know usually if
you have a tax charge you know you want
to make sure that you know what the
person is you want to make sure that the
person is not going to escape and indeed
you want to be able to hold on to some
assets but why that required as i said
to move 1,500 works of art a 14-hour
works of art from his apartment to away
how still puzzles me yeah so many
puzzles because the authorities aren't
telling us much Alex and yeah well
that's probably due to the fact that
there are many open questions with
regard to the two possible tax offenses
we don't even know whether the tax
offenses have been committed that's what
they're trying to find out but coming
back to thee to the question of
publication of all pictures and lists
list of all pictures that have been
found in the flat it is certainly
correct not to to publish them all
around straight away because there is a
privacy issue in the sense for those
pictures which undoubtedly belong to mr.
Gurlitt which where there's no question
that he owns them legitimately so we
have a mixture we have a number of
pictures which have been cut off from
Ron someone else
bought under illegitimate circumstances
and others which legitimately were
bought by him so this mixture leads to
thee to the consequence I think rightly
to sort out those pictures which
undoubtedly have been taken from Jews
and their families and whit owned should
be reclaimed by others and the other
part of pictures there is no reason to
publish them so we have a complicated
situation before we move on really you
live in the United States so what brings
you are you being a detective why you're
in Germany right now well I'm here
working on another case which is the max
turn collection also from distal Dorf
where girl had left after the war has
anyone contacted you about this case yet
about the degree audit case yeah well of
course from from the minute it was on on
the internet I received my first phone
calls and and of course people you know
wanted to know more about it and whether
any connection with any cases that I'm
I'm working on it of course it does
because girl its role was so significant
but but again I have to say legally I'm
not quite sure where this is going to go
I mean now we have 25 pictures online
but but where are we going to turn with
our claims not not to the people who put
it online not to the building government
we would have to find out mr. grid
ourselves and hand him you know our
letter with with our claim so there may
be no one then at the end of the day I
think we have names with we have some
additional information but we have sort
of more mysteries on this on top of
mysteries a very final question if this
deal is reached with mr. Gurlitt and he
says ok drop the charges the state can
have all of the art is it then the
state's responsibility to give this art
back or even to compensate what if the
girl it decides to donate his art
collections right or the German
government yes and German government
would of course be under under
tremendous pressure based on know the
washing principles and other
international understandings to sort it
out and return whatever it can be
alright well the story has some long
legs on it I think we're gonna be
talking about this again let's move on
bring this show right here to Berlin
Berlin is front and center right now in
the NSA spying scandal one reason
allegations of course at the NSA tapped
the German Chancellor's mobile phone
another reason Berlin appears to be
destination number 14 people connected
to leaking classified information we've
spent two weeks on this show disgusting
Edward Snowden's request to come to
Berlin to assist the government in its
spying investigation Snowden has not
made it to Berlin yet but if he does
he'll have plenty of company Germany has
been rocked by allegations that both the
US and Britain have been listening in on
Chancellor on lomira chol and her
government from their embassies in
Berlin but against the backdrop of this
increased espionage activity a growing
number of web activists involved with
NSA leaker Edward Snowden are also
seeking refuge in Berlin British
journalists and WikiLeaks staffer Sarah
Harrison seen here on the left has been
working with Snowden since his arrival
in Russia she's now in Berlin because
her lawyers say she's no longer safe in
Britain us activists such as Jacob
Appelbaum or Laura Poitras who filmed
the Snowden interview also moved to
Berlin at least in part to escape
harassment and intimidation by the US
government will Germany strict data
protection laws suffice to provide a
safe haven for these activists Alexander
is that what we're looking at have has
Germany created a refuge for people who
leaked I don't think this this happened
systematically it's certainly a critical
discussion going on in Germany probably
more critical on the NSA scandal than
anywhere else but just to make it clear
data protection law is not is it's not a
function of data protection law to
protect whistleblowers or refugees in
fact we don't even have a
proper legal protection for
whistleblowers in this country's in this
country as opposed to the United Kingdom
for instance where they paradoxically
have such a law but I do think that
Berlin has a positive environment where
lots of startups are here based in
Berlin a lot of nerds the cows Computer
Club is based here so there may be some
sympathetic environment for four people
around WikiLeaks to to come to the city
it's an interesting color to put you
know nerds and whistleblowers here you
know into the same pot but it is there
though there is something here because
we do have all of these people coming to
Berlin for some reason they feel safe
here first maybe they feel like they
can't be watched and tapped as easily
but I mean the German Chancellor can
tell a different story can't you well if
what we learnt during the last four
months is that every one of us is can be
watched there's no safe haven anywhere
if you look at the NSA and other
intelligence agencies so it's all
relative relative protection from from
monitoring anywhere on the world but in
in Berlin certainly we witness a very
concentrated discussion on what the
consequences from these findings which
we owe to Edward Snowden we should draw
and that's probably an attractive moment
and interactive element why so many
people are coming to the city among
other things which make Berlin certainly
very attractive what about I'm Sarah
Harrison she is a reporter from the UK
she has been told openly if you come
home you know you could be detained and
so her decision was to come to Berlin
that's a big statement isn't it feeling
what's your take on that well in certain
countries as you know particular United
States this whole thing is still under
the headline of national security which
i think is being used to put it mildly
to pretty much justify them as anything
you know in terms of this creepy kind of
spying on anything that people you know
exchange in terms of communication and
apparently it is also being extended to
individuals who are associated with
leaking information that there are now
Mallis providing you know help to the
enemy that they are violating national
security interest so it's it's it's I
think is a very dangerous mixture of you
know global spying activities to
whatever limit you know technology
allows you to do and and and pursuing
individuals you know who are modest
resisting this kind of attitude and and
and all justifying it because of
national security yeah I was um earlier
this year I was at the whistleblowers
award here in Berlin and a statement was
made that the Germans have gotten it
right because of their past the
Americans need to take lessons from the
Germans in terms of respecting each
other and each other's privacy father
Simon do you agree with that is does
that then make Berlin the better place
to be I think Berlin's still plays a
very big role in the international
politics not only because of the euro
crisis but also the relationship between
the Americans and the Europeans I think
the what happened in Berlin has a major
impact on how international
relationships will be conducted in the
future and how do you think I mean a lot
of people would say that we're walking
on thin ice right now in relations with
Washington I think there is more a need
for more dialogue between nations and
more transparency of course if the
economy plays a major role in conducting
this dialogue stand it will become more
complicated billion how do people in the
United States how do they look at Berlin
or easily even on the radar right now I
mean they haven't even been talking
about Edward Snowden as much as we have
in Europe
they well Edward Snowden this is a
traitor basically and I think that that
the official view has not changed on
that it's it's clearly an embarrassment
you know that they spied on Angela
Merkel and another foreign foreign
leaders but again thanks to the
overwhelming concern about national
security that's you know any of this
could a terrorist in the Middle East I'm
afraid you know whatever agreements we
may have I don't think that's going to
prevent the NSA from from pursuing
whatever you know spying activities they
think they can pursue and I mean I'm a
student of history among other things
I've read you know countless
intelligence documents from the 20th
century and it's my impression spies spy
and they spy to whatever extent they are
able to spy so so I think you know
whatever they're not going to change but
I don't think so i don't think the NSA
is going to what discontinued certain
programs but Alexander why does it feel
like then Berlin is is a safer place for
people who dare to delete classified
information or people who work with
those leakers I'm not sure if Berlin is
really a safer place than say Paris or
Madrid or Rome but i agree with father
Simon that certainly Berlin the German
government plays a pivotal role right
now in the international on the
international stage if any sensible
reasonable consequences are to be drawn
from this we need an international
agreement where are the limits to
intelligence agencies maybe they will
never accept any limits but the German
government has now initiated a United
Nations resolution together with the
Brazilian government to formulate
certain general limits to this and to
the protection of secrecy of
telecommunications this is vital and on
the other hand we need technical methods
of self-defense we need a do you think
though that hacktivists people who are
activists and who are computer hackers
do they deserve special protection
that's getting a lot of talk around the
world
right now and they're talking about it a
lot here in Berlin do they deserve
protection I think they do I think we do
need a national and an international
framework for protecting whistleblowers
which have disclosed information
stemming from violations of the law even
maybe human rights violations there is
no justification to keep this kind of
things secret they've even been
international documents being drafted
there is a limit to to keeping
information secret if it stems from
human rights violations so that's a very
essential point to make and maybe the
german government i hope the german
government will take this point up does
it seems that the NSA has worked the
manectric concerns me has worked with
some of the dick communications
companies you know to access information
I mean I have a telephone line through
AT&T so so you know the whole world
knows that now yeah telling me you know
18 teaspoon of me we protect your
privacy I get this in the mail every
month well yeah trust will you just set
it on an international show so the whole
world knows Alexander before before we
before we let you go let me just ask you
in the morning when you get up and go to
work I mean how does it sit with you
knowing that this city is being known
now as I as the place to be if you are a
whistleblower if you're a activist is
that something your office is proud of
I'm glad that that the city offers
offers a place to be for these people
it's not for me to claim to be proud on
this but I think that's a good
development all right we have to wrap it
up there gentlemen thank you very much
for coming on the show today that is
going to wrap up this agenda of it this
edition i should say of agenda with
Brent Gough remember you can contact me
anytime with your thoughts on the show
you can find me on Facebook you can
tweet me at brent Goff TV or you can
send me an email you see the address on
your screen if you want to watch the
show go to our website or watch us on
youtube I'm Brent Goff in Berlin join me
next time when i set the agenda
you